[Music]
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste I'm Connor and I'm with the boys
as usual Joey and Khan that's them
they're the boys
we need to learn how to podcast again
because it's been the first time we've
been in the studio for like
maybe well we never left but uh in real
life we did leave to a lot of different
places it's been five weeks it's been a
long time since we've been in uh since
we've been in the podcast Studio Church
America twice yeah you did oh yeah you
did because Hawaii is America yeah yeah
true yeah Cycles all across Kyushu I
always forget I always forget Hawaii is
America yeah
I forgot about that until well I knew
about that but for for some reason I
would hope so yeah yeah I I knew but
like for some reason there was always
this like mental Gap where Hawaii is
Hawaii even though like it's you know an
American state I still always felt that
Hawaii is its own separate thing in my
mind
um even though it's not uh and then I
went and then we went to Hawaii and I'm
like oh this is actually America okay
this this is actually America it's uh
yeah we uh just went to Hawaii for uh
Kawaii con which was very very fun it
was making mention mine in first
Corner's trip to Hawaii how was it it's
all right
always nice always definitely a good
place I should never ask a British
person if something's good or not yes
the answer would just be it's like it's
like Disneyland for adults if you ever
go to Hawaii you just kind of feel like
the instead of like you know when you go
to certain parts in like Spain they'll
have like a resort it just seems like
the whole island or at least that's part
of this well especially Waikiki yeah
just turned into like a resort for
people with too much money and want to
drink alcohol wasn't it something like I
think I think you or someone was telling
me we're the cameraman for something and
the cameraman who lived there for like
30 years yeah he told me that Hawaii
this could be [__] we might need to
factor
um he told me that Hawaii has one
million people who live on it yeah like
locals yeah people who live there but at
any given time there's 10 million people
on the island
like a ratio of like wanted it's like
token like yeah
a lot of tourists
um but like most of them stay in the
where we were which is like Waikiki
which I guess is the touristy part it's
basically like yeah just it feels like a
Disneyland but for adults yeah Kyle were
they capping or I have a 6.7 million
visitors compared to 1.4 million
residents
so it's like five to one pretty much
still insane yeah considering because
that means like when you're looking
you're walking around or driving like
you're almost always looking at a
tourist without realizing it or
especially if you're in like Waikiki
which we were for the most yeah yeah
yeah I mean I would have liked to
explore more of the other Islands
because like Hawaii was like incredible
but I think my mental image of Hawaii
before going did not add up to the image
that I landed in what was your mental
image of Hawaii I don't know maybe
Island like yeah a bit maybe a bit more
like Island like maybe a bit you know
closer to Nature or stuff like that you
know I've traveled to like different
tropical Islands before yeah and
obviously there was you know there have
been like big cities on some of these
islands but nothing that really compared
to Waikiki yeah it kind of felt like
Connor said it was like kind of like a
theme park I landed and I'm like oh [__]
it's spring break 24 7. every day of the
year that's kind of what it felt like
felt bad for the locals they have to
deal with that [__] yeah I'm sure that's
what I'm sure that's what I show it
feels like to the locals that live there
yeah probably probably pretty much the
same yeah I mean I'm British I was like
yeah tight I'm not a big beach guy not a
fan of beaches
I honestly I gotta avoid that you're
blending into that [__] I I normally
stay away from beaches I'm not I just
why okay why are you not a beach person
that's what I've always wanted to know
because you've said this sand actually
is the worst feeling thing now Luke
Skywalker I I think that people mock
that scene and I thought he's right like
I don't send is like just something that
I despise and when I'm on it I can't
relax so would you prefer it if it was a
Pebble Beach a rock beef no I don't want
any beef
let's let's all get sound into this
Sanders sound is Zone Seven I like scuba
diving wait were you literally not a
lifesaver at one point in your life yeah
yeah oh you're in a place I love
swimming I love scuba diving I love but
I hate it you don't like the ocean of
like oh the other Ocean's eye yeah
ocean mid I I just like I if we could
have like
just the pool kind of setup but for all
of the ocean like I can climb out and I
could be done you'll that that is the
most privileged scene thing you've said
in a long time I've said a lot of
privilege things I know it has been zero
days I don't like sand like it just
sucks
I like because it's like okay okay let's
say it right you gotta you go to the
beach right I don't care about what you
like gone that's about me I was about to
make a point and they just made you just
made it seem like I just made an AI
generator sentence I like the ocean I
like the ocean I thought you were done
the Cadence of what you were talking
about
what happened was I was starting my
sentence I was like oh Connor hasn't
finished his point and then you stopped
and I was like well because now I
realize okay okay it's like you go okay
let's say you go to the beach right yeah
if you go in shoes it feels gross feels
nasty I don't like it okay if you sit
down on it I've gotta sandals all the
way man you got to go to the beach and
sound yeah okay yeah right that's fine
we can go in sandals yeah I mean I love
my vessels man but not for the beach man
not for the beach it's like then like
you let's see lay a towel down towel
gets all [__] Sandy I hate that I
hate that so much I'll get Sandy if
you're like new to the beach well I mean
it's pretty it's pretty easy to avoid
getting sick but then like let's say I
go into the ocean I want to dry myself
and it's like okay that's why you bring
another towel yeah but this is already
this is already so annoying life hack
bring two towels this is already so
frustrating that I haven't been two
towels and then like I don't know I
think it's worth going through all that
just for The Vibes there's just
something about a beachfly like that you
can't because I actually agree with you
I do not like sand and I don't like
swimming in the ocean but yet I love
beaches just because there is just a
certain Vibe especially when you can
feel the Ocean Air there's just
something about this this is like it's
living yeah yeah this is living man and
I say that growing up in Brighton we
have one of the worst beaches I've been
to in the world I mean every British
Beach is the worst Beach I've been in
the world but I still [__] loved it I
mean something about being next to a big
body of water is just especially during
covid and especially living in Tokyo I
miss that a lot you know because we we
have beaches here in Japan uh but unless
you go you know down south yeah it's not
like great beaches yeah
um I'm not a fan of beaches it's kind of
where I'm I don't know like I I could
enjoy the beach more if I like
let's say I went like Giga bougie and we
had like a a like we're staying like an
Airbnb yeah like access to the beach
yeah then I'm kind of down because then
act like a beach resort because then you
just go back into the hotel or whatever
when you're done like yeah it's the
whole like traveling to the beach which
I also hate a lot of the time because
you gotta like you like you you're
dressed for the beach but then you don't
want to I don't want to dress as an
Australian I'm dying on the inside this
is like this is the average Australian
commute yeah this is basically I hate
that I think it's just the British that
pardoned me that just hates it yeah and
so are there not any beaches in Wales uh
there are but they're so there's some
there's one really nice in South Wales
called like the Gower or mumbles it's
called and it's pretty nice yeah and
it's like this but it's more of like a
looks like a Game of Thrones Stone
formation it's like a giant place it
looks amazing that's right right but
it's not really like a maybe in the
summer you go there but I never did I
just went there to like walk across the
beautiful thing yeah there's some up
north at a pretty decent but a lot of
them are terrible a lot of needles a lot
of stones they stink yeah the tide like
difference is crazy oh really yeah
um yeah don't go to England for his
beaches or just Britain in general I
don't think anyone wants here that's why
we go outside not even British people do
yeah yeah but then if you don't have the
beach if you're not a big beach guy and
you also kind of don't Vibe with the
city of like Waikiki in Hawaii
what's everybody to do so we ended up
drinking craft beer most of the time
yeah that's right which was great that
was great the food no I was amazing yeah
that was probably the best part of one
one thing that I was really impressive
was the actual locals man oh yeah
everyone's really nice everyone had such
an awesome energy to them in Hawaii the
amount of times I did this while I was
there man I was just like I get this now
I don't know where locals do this this
is the vibe of Hawaii 100 it is totally
Vibes and everyone is just on the same
level I thought people would be like
much more relaxed over there but they
bring the energy and it's such a it's a
relaxed [__] energy yeah yeah I've
never seen such a relaxer relax run they
need to be in their hype when they want
yeah people were generally just a lot
happier there which was nice I felt a
little bit safer as well than most of
the US yeah
um I don't know if it is or if that's
just like a weird misconception I think
it's just purely because we're in
Waikiki but like I feel yeah compared to
other big cities and other American
states like yeah it was weird because I
almost forgot at one point I was like oh
we're in America yeah technically why do
I feel so safe just like well walking
around you realize you're in America
when there's like four lanes yeah cars
and you're like oh I'm back but I could
have but like there were so many days
where I would just be like I'm just
gonna go for a walk you know even if
it's at night or whatever right yeah you
couldn't catch me doing that in L.A or
on the mainland anywhere like or on the
mainland anyway right but in Hawaii for
some reason I was like yeah no it's no
one has a gun Here No One's Gonna stab
me here it's like everyone's just
chilling out when you know there's
definitely no guarantee Mainland sounds
so cool to say yeah yeah Attack on Titan
the mainland standing on the Baseline
over there like do I find my enemies
over there in L.A
it was good though I mean I enjoyed it
uh it was definitely the people that I I
liked the most yeah out of all of the
like everything about Hawaii and the
food the food and food people were the
best yeah yeah I'm like the weather was
pretty good we had a lot of rain but I I
like that generally not a fan of humid
and hot places I say that I live in
Japan yeah um but I'm an AC fiend here I
don't leave AC areas I'm actually a fan
of tropical I know you are yeah it's a
Thai though that's not fair oh it's got
a natural buff to it it's not just about
being tired
[__] off it is about people you were
born in the warm rain look look anything
is better than British rain okay British
rain is the most depressing thing I've
seen on the face of this Earth all right
like there's there's a difference
between like the [__] cold wet rain
that's not even really rain it's just
like someone blew of Razz like God blew
of raspberry on you bro it's just
unpleasant to go out versus just getting
like rain that just cools down the
temperature by a few degrees and it's
just oh he says that but the day before
we left there was a flood warning and it
was torrential rain it was it was pretty
bad yeah I think because when you're an
island in like the middle of the Pacific
Ocean yeah the rain is so weird it like
appears for like five seconds yeah no
jokes it's like an on off switch
sometimes just 10 seconds gone yeah
again and then none and then torrential
gone it's so weird in the UK if it rains
it's like well Susan uh get the biscuits
and the scones because it's gonna be
raining for the next four days and it's
not gonna stop and it's gonna be
torrential yeah yeah and it just doesn't
stop uh yeah yeah it's a no joke it's
always raining and yeah because we
checked the weather report uh just
before we flew to Hawaii and you know we
saw the weather report and we were
getting worried because we had a
week-long like period or that was just
rain yeah but I knew what it meant if
it's like tropical weather just rain on
the weather report means it's going to
rain hard for five minutes I've been
then ever and then for like the rest of
like the 24 hours maybe it'll rain in
like the night time yeah or the evening
time uh but it will come in like five
minute bursts or like 20 minutes at most
and then it will like clear up it will
dry up and if you got and uh if you're
outside for those five minutes well [__]
you you are getting so tough [__] yeah
no nobody's nobody's carrying around an
umbrella here man you either leave with
an umbrella you can't just like pick one
up randomly sure yeah although I will
say the most important part about the
Hawaii trip was that Gart and I are
officially part of the moped gang now
yes I mean I I was the one that got
those boys into it sorry I have now
officially joined the moped game yeah I
mean part of the reason I've become part
of the moped moped gang was because in
the last month I went to Vietnam oh yeah
we didn't talk about that yeah yeah I
guess it's been so long I guess we
should go in chronological order right
right we're way out of order yeah we're
way out of order we went in reverse
order but yeah I uh I went to Vietnam
changed my life because
oh you're like a white guy
changed my life when I say that as a you
know already Southeast Asian it's been
to uh Thailand a bunch of times my life
uh I am now part of the scooter gang was
that was that your first time it was my
first time right now
um so yeah I mentioned Paul
yeah it's funny because it's only like
an hour away from Bangkok so I don't
know why I've never been to Vietnam or a
lot of other Southeast Asian countries
that's that's what happens when
something is too close yeah you end up
never going because you always think
it's within reach yes exactly it's like
Japanese people never going to Korea
yeah it's like it's just right there
yeah I'm definitely I'll go with you
that's fine yeah my entire life I'd
never gone on that trip for just an hour
even though it probably takes long to
fly to Hokkaido from here yeah but uh
yeah it was a very very short flight and
uh I you know I had a friend who was
living there so I was like yeah I'll
come visit you for the weekend first
time in Vietnam show me around
um so in my mind most Southeast Asian
countries are basically the same except
for Singapore Singapore Singapore's like
its own thing that's that's not real
southeast Asia right right
it's a friend with the the ridge house
yeah yeah Singapore is not a real
southeast Asia right
this is the Malaysia nobody asks
Malaysian boy
you know you guys have a good GDP you
know people follow the rules there
that's that's not real southeast Asia
man come on come on come on stop stop
baking guys stop playing chewing gum is
illegal yeah exactly right your streets
are clean yeah the privilege yeah
you're gonna go on here you know that's
not that's not the southeast Asia right
now but wow yeah so I mean what I will
say is uh yeah Vietnam is very very
similar to Thailand shocker
[Music]
so I I thought that I was prepared for
the scooter culture there because I
thought scooters were just everywhere in
Southeast Asia yeah um which they are in
Thailand as well but in Vietnam it is a
whole on a whole nother level it's it
was actually like [__] shocking to
see how many like the scooter to car
ratio which I got told I don't know if
this is true I got told it's like 80
scooters and motorcycles versus 20 cars
on the roads I don't know if that's true
but it definitely felt like the road now
yeah
uh and yeah just so my entire life my
entire life I was scared of Scooters or
scared of like I think I'd partly been
conditioned to not like to not get into
like the scooter culture and partly I
had some bad experiences as a kid uh
when I tried to learn how to ride a
scooter for the first time right uh and
uh I remember like when I was like seven
or something my cousin was like oh do
you want to give it a go didn't tell me
anything and all I did was just rev up
oh no it just flew forward and it fell
on me and I'm like I'm never running a
scooter again in my life and also I grew
up my parents were just like you are not
getting a scooter you are never riding
on scooters those are dangerous do not
do not do that we are not a household
that rides scooters here so I I so my
entire life my entire life I'd just been
conditioned to be afraid of scooters
inside school and anti-scooter household
but in Vietnam you don't really have a
choice you don't really have a choice
you are getting on a scooter whether you
like it or not because even if you want
to go somewhere close by nobody really
uses cars for like uh their equivalent
of uber there which is grab everyone
just uses grab bikes and the first thing
that kind of sold me on this idea of you
know possibly riding a scooter in
Vietnam is a everyone wears helmets
what the [__] Thailand what the [__] I
mean like when you guys were in Thailand
how many people did you see wearing
helmets motorcycles literally zero zeros
I don't even think they had seat belts
yeah dude half of them weren't even
wearing shoes yeah they're literally
just [__] free freeing the beasts and
also the hair just [__] flying out
behind them going at like 80 kilometers
an hour and they're just like yeah hell
yeah on the highway and I'm like all
right well yeah you're waiting to happen
yeah I mean I think Thailand has at one
point at one point was like the most
dangerous roads on the planet I believe
that and you know I I totally believe
that as well and uh so I thought okay
this is just normal in Southeast Asia
going to Vietnam bloom my [__] mind
because I it made me realize oh people
can actually care about their safety and
follow the rules and uh well follow the
rules in terms of at least wearing
helmets even if you order like a grab
bike
um they every every motorbike taxi comes
with a spare helmet for the passengers
so I was just like if they can make it
work work on Thailand make it work man
what's what's going on well I mean
throwing it back to the Hawaii thing as
well like I feel like I'd have to
negotiate in Thailand for the time now
it's actually 20 bucks yeah yeah yeah
yeah what the [__] man give me the
helmet it's not weird because like
throwing it back to the Hawaii thing
like there's so many like mopeds and
scooters there as well yeah no one was
wearing helmets right right even in
Hawaii even in Hawaii they weren't
wearing helmets Yeah and I remember
because like when we rented our scooters
in Hawaii I was like I want the helmet I
want my safety and the guys really the
guy literally told us and it's like oh
that's good normally you have to like
really fight for my clients to like wear
helmets and they rarely do they really
do Jesus
um so yeah my first experience was
getting picked up by my mate at the
airport and he was like had a small
luggage on me and I was like where's the
car and he was like there is no car
welcome to Vietnam welcome to Vietnam
traveling to a place and bringing
luggage yeah [__] [__] so so I was
like when I put the luggage and he was
like welcome to Vietnam baby and so he
just he he just you know this was
compared to compare it to uh compared to
some of the other [__] I saw people
putting on motorcycles this was like
this was tame but so he just put out the
front and I was like oh my God are you
safe with that and he was like yep it's
so it's all good this is actually a
pretty small luggage actually oh my God
uh and uh he just uh after we dropped
the luggage off back he kind of like
took uh took me around on uh took me
around on the bike and just went on it
went on a tour of the entire city
varicious I don't know there's just
something freeing about exploring a city
on the back of a bike especially if it's
in Vietnam yeah because there's I can't
really describe feeling of going up to
the of like stopping at the traffic
lights and you are with an army of
school you're the first one there I have
a new stop and then and then you just
hear the buzzing and then the bike again
there is a certain frequency of the
Vietnam bikes where are you just here
this is gone accidentally joined it back
again without realizing it yeah it's it
kind of felt like you you stop the lies
and you hear the buzzing as the army of
scooters just I I stop at the light she
looked around you're surrounded by
scooters and then everyone's waiting for
the lights to turn green and you just
hear uh you just hear an army of room
it's like four guys on bikes
everyone goes off and nobody crashes it
was like playing real life Mario Kart
man you saw some people who had the
speed boost some people were just like
you know he chilled to the Blue Shield
yeah
and yeah that was just that was such an
awesome experience I was like I really
really want to try getting a scooter but
I don't know if I should I don't know if
I should you know my parents you make it
sound like Vietnam was only scootering
it was that's all you did that's I mean
any food I eat a lot of food but that
this that was kind of like the highlight
of my trip I think because I remember
the the entire time I was like I think
I'm gonna get a scooter but I don't know
I don't know if my parents are gonna be
happy I don't know if my parents are
going to be happy and then so after this
you know awesome bike tour that I took
with my mates we were just standing
outside
having a drink outside a bar and it was
like 4 P.M and I was just you know when
you're just like on the cusp of being
convinced of something yeah I was I was
like on that cusp and then as we're just
sitting down having a children just
enjoying the Vibes I just see I just see
this couple riding along and they're in
a bright red Vesper
and they just they just it was it was a
single Vesper driving down this road on
Vietnam and I could I could feel
something my brain just click
right on shoes
fast and I'm like I turned to my man I'm
like I'm getting a vessel I've just
decided it now I'm I rarely in my life
has something in my brain just clicked
that I know I'm going to make a
spontaneous purchase yeah but I I went I
went to him I was like as soon as I land
in Thailand the first thing I'm doing
I'm buying a Vespa and the first thing I
did was I landed in Thailand my parents
picked me up uh didn't even say hi I was
like Dad I'm buying a Vespa and he was
like what what what's what's going on
what do you mean you're buying
investment you're just here for another
five days of like I don't care that I've
made my decision I'm buying a Vespa I'm
a changed man and I'll be honest uh even
though I could only ride it for five
days in Thailand I'm sure I'll be back
sometime but it was it's waiting for you
it was like it was like a fish being
like a fish being introduced to water
for the first time I had realized that
this was in my body's video yeah yeah
discovers water for the first time I I
just realized just riding the motorcycle
and riding investment around Bangkok it
was it was my like it was in my blood
this entire time I I had tried to I
tried to reject what was in my bloodline
but it's it's it just felt so right and
uh yeah I love how you went to Vietnam
in the first 20 minutes all you were
talking about as a [__] scooter like
this is everything this is everything
made almost great as well I mean like
food better than Thai food or his time
oh [__]
yeah I'm sorry I'm
I'm sorry Vietnamese people
Chili's man you know you need to put
some chilies in there take your helmet
off man yeah okay
there's only so much Sriracha you can
put on [__] you know I need some I need
some actual chilies in my Cuisine but
not Vietnamese food
sorry
but he said he eats Communists but now
Vietnamese food was great I mean like
the first thing I did after I you know
got out the airport was I had to get
some money out and I had no this is my
first time in Vietnam so and I didn't
Google this before so I had no like
inkling of what the conversion rate was
so you're scammed uh no I put in my I
put in my cards uh and you know I
normally you gauge how much you can take
out by what they allow you to take yeah
right yeah so the maximum amount uh you
could take out of this ATM that's you
know unless you like insert a natural
number was 2 million Dong
and I was like that sounds like a lot
you know what I'm gonna take out one
million Dong that's probably gonna last
me the entire trip yeah Google why don't
you Google oh wait I was in a rush
because my mate was waiting for me he
was ripping up his bike
yeah so I was like God damn I'm a
Vietnamese millionaire I've I've got the
cash and so I I get the million now I go
that's my mate I was like I got a
million it's not a lot and he just looks
at me dead in the eye and goes nope
that's a 30 quid you got there
Bank fees are probably more than that
yeah right I can't [__] damn it uh
but yeah I mean aside basically I did
two things on uh in Vietnam just go
around and try a bunch of food uh and
right about ride around on motorcycle
and uh go to some local bars that's
that's all you need so [__] pumps
because I get to go in June and I'm just
hearing about this I'm like I'm trying
to convince my parents yeah like we need
to get mopeds yeah I might if if we're
not [__] you guys I'm going on a moped
because I'm a changed man now I've
learned the moped ways in Hawaii yeah I
mean it's like any other Southeast Asian
country the street food is just it's
insane like tried my first like local
ban me yeah which was like a Vietnamese
kind of sandwich yeah they have uh they
have a lot of bread there that's uh
dude
I
mean I I don't know how much I don't
know how much my opinion is worth but uh
because I'd like to try this bread yeah
I'll try for myself yeah because because
they're a lot of their culture revolve
revolves around like ban me uh because
you can get it like every combini and
there's so many like street food stalls
that sell ban me it's the one where they
put like a [__] ton of coriander yeah
yeah that's just all the interviews yeah
that's just Vietnamese food and I
remember like uh we went to a fast store
as well and having fur with the ban me
bread bro that my third eye open man
because I've had fire before but I've
never had it with like the local band
yeah you just I was just like oh
Southeast Asian people can do bread it's
it's maybe it's just Thailand that's
just [__] up bread man and I bet that
costs like 50 cents or something yeah
you think about it I didn't see a single
bread no in Thailand no I don't see it I
remember I remember going back to
Thailand for the last month and uh I
wanted a sandwich and
and I level impossible we ordered the
sandwich and I don't know what it is
about Thailand bread but the sun most of
the places you have even if it's a
bougie looking place all the bread is
like sweet it's like sweet bread even
for sandwiches it's like a career it's
garlic bread I was like what is this
maybe [__] maybe the boys have
poisoned my mind because I don't
remember bread being this bad or maybe
maybe that's why I just never ate bread
as a kid because it everywhere I live
bread was just [__] you've had the real
world in Belgium that's pretty good Brad
yeah the bread in Belgium was [__]
not the best at it sorry Belgium yeah
I'm I'm discovering my bread Journey now
I think it's quite young age of 32 okay
I'm I'm just fine it's fine
um and yeah just uh had a bunch of like
the street food local food uh but one
thing I did notice is that everything in
there is also like sweet there's a big
Coffee Culture there I um took me to a
egg coffee place
I've heard about this an egg what the
[__] is that so you know how you have a
latte you have like the espresso no no
don't tell me what I think there you
have you have the espresso and then they
froth up the milk so imagine that except
they use egg whites for it
yeah it's honestly actually it kind of
sounds like you're not gonna lie
actually
pretty damn good all right I I actually
like it okay let me show you is this
good
maybe it's egg white coffee good
have you had it
is it egg yolk is that is it good
it's okay okay it's kind of like this
this is what it looks like it looks like
a creme brulee yeah so it's if you
forget the fact that you are drinking a
coffee and treat this more like a
dessert then is it sweet yeah it's sweet
right yeah I mean I might like it it
looks like kind of like a like a dessert
it's kind of it's kind of like like a
middle a perfect middle bit between like
kind of like a drink and a custard
yeah it's kind of kind of like it's kind
of like tiramisu but just yeah
we just said is it's a deconstructive
terms
I would have been on board it's a
reconstruction it's a latte but with
yolk I'm like what the [__] is that tell
me it's a Tiramisu deconstructed I'm
like okay well now okay that sounds good
I mean that isn't that literally what a
Tiramisu is yeah
let's get there yeah all right well okay
now I said I said I was gonna be a hater
but now I'm actually yeah I'm interested
so easy yeah
soon he's like all right
I know I'm not debating that yeah
tiramisu I mean like yeah like I said
there's a big Coffee Culture there
there's a lot a lot of coffee shops is
Vietnam the one as well that has that
coffee that like comes from like the the
cat poop
[Applause]
this episode is sponsored by Honey the
easy way to save When shopping on your
iPhone or Computer Boys how do you feel
after you find a good deal well thanks
to Honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one I can find to your carts Connor
explain how honey Works to the audience
I thought you'd never ask Jerry imagine
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites when you check out the honey
button appears and all you have to do is
Click apply coupons what if you seconds
as Holly searches for coupons it can
find for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop what did you save money on Connor
well recently had trashed his
headquarters we actually ran out of
trash cans and we managed to save 20 on
the trash cans it was a really messy
office but did you know guys honey
doesn't just work on desktops it works
on your iPhone too just activated on
Safari on your phone and save on the go
oh my God if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out up straight up and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid self
supporting the boys as well us two us
two get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com trash taste that's
joinhoney.com trash taste smash that
link and down below about the episode
this episode is sponsored by AFK Arena
AFK Arena's fourth anniversary
celebration is starting now participate
in the anniversary event and get 100
summons AFK arena with it stunning 2D
art style and Idol enjoyment with the
perfect combination of collectible RPGs
now has 40 million users worldwide
whether or not you have played this game
the 107th anniversary and the crossover
3-0 will be the best time for you to
enjoy the excellent aesthetic experience
and idle fun of AFK for the fourth
anniversary in Crossover with re-02 new
Heroes RAM and Amelia will come to the
world of AFK
you can try this two powerful and unique
collaboration characters a million Ram
free for three days after which there'll
be ways to redeem the heroes for free
there's also a brand new thematic
dungeon in it enjoy your adventure with
REM and Amelia their power will be there
for you to win battles and the treasure
I don't care any you don't need to spend
a lot of time grinding for Gears
leveling up you can just Auto collect
the resources even while you're away to
set the game from time to time and you
will find your team is getting stronger
every single time in turn you can focus
on enjoying the various gameplay modes
available such as PV stories Dungeons
and raid bosses Arena King towers and
more so make sure to download AFK Arena
through the link in the description
below and get your 100 summons right now
Ram get Ram just get it make the choice
make the correct Choice correct Choice
back to the video but yeah honestly I
only spent uh like two three days there
and I already really want to go back I
think two or three days is like kind of
perfect for gauging A vibe yeah like if
you want to come yeah because I don't
know and that I used to I used to be
like a one-week person I was like I need
a week but now I feel like one week's
too much I'm like I want three four days
we're literally traveling the entire
thing if you're traveling all around I
think that's fine like you know let's
say you you're flying into this major
city oh no we're not going to be in like
one city for like more than three or
four days yeah that's that's good I mean
we went to like Bangkok I thought that
like traveling to a city for like two or
three days is like a really good way to
kind of just get a feel for the vibe and
try some food I I think it's like an
awesome amount of time as well because
have you ever been to like a place where
you've booked it out for a week and
after three days you're like I'm done
yeah yeah yeah we've got four more days
of this I'd rather leave a place wishing
I stayed more yeah than staying there
too long and wishing I left earlier
exactly so it's like you know I can
always come back yeah so I'm already
like planning to go back to Vietnam when
I can I want to explore more of the
country as well because yeah the two
three days was more kind of like a Vibe
check if I kind of like Vibe with the
place there and now I wanna I wanna
scoot all around Vietnam man I want to
do a road trip around Vietnam on
scooters man that's trash day special I
I can't yeah literally I came back to
Vietnam and I was like a changed man
because I would not stop talking about
scooters I like the first if you've been
talking about scooters
I have tenfold yeah the amount that you
were before I mean he convinced me
yeah how was it uh scooting around
Hawaii Joey dude it's so good yeah like
I I knew I was gonna enjoy it because
like you know I've always wanted to ride
the scooter for the longest time but
like it's not really a thing in
Australia for one because Australia's
just like too big you can't get around
in a scooter yeah and in Japan you need
to get like a license which I'm going to
get now that I'm a change man so I was
like we had the opportunity to write one
in in Hawaii because they're so easy to
get and they're so affordable to get
yeah so yeah like I think uh one of the
days like
um in the middle of the convention uh
all three of us you know we went out and
Connor did the stream and uh got Nye and
Nabi were on our mopeds and yeah we just
drove around for like two three hours
around like the coastline this beautiful
[__] coaster yeah it was really nice
like Cliff uh like area
um it's nice to get out of the city
honestly oh my God riding on that road
was just Enlightenment it was so good we
did the giant truck or I'm sorry it's
not called a truck this is a Jeep
people get annoyed if you refer to a
Jeep as a truck oh really yeah
apparently a Jeep is not a truck as I
found out even if it is in the style of
a pickup truck yeah it's very much a
truck it is not a truck because there's
always a Jeep when it's a Jeep yeah
um which I rented and that was fun to
drive I just wanted to rent the biggest
car they had available and just just
feel like a menace on the road you want
to feel America I want to feel America
yeah I want to get it and I feel like I
do get it yeah there was a there is a a
joy that comes from having a car that
can always handle every situation and
handle as many people as you need and if
you need to move [__] even I didn't move
[__] well we tried to the Vespa that's a
big fail oh yeah that's all right yeah I
mean like I I think the the reason we
went like scooter gang aside from you
know me being going through a phase now
I guess are you in your scooter phase
I'm in my scooter face third life crisis
[Music]
I've got like 32 years of scooting to
get back in my system that I missed out
yeah like I'm like making money his
whole personality is going to be like
scooting like one of those like people
get into rock climbing but they're like
yeah actually my whole thing is now
scooted actually I'm just I actually
like I have gloves yeah
he's like what's CC mean I refuse to
scoot without my leather glass it's just
wild so you can you can always tell what
phase I'm going through by looking at my
YouTube recommendations and right now
like my entire homepage is just
motorbike and scooter videos so you can
definitely tell the kind of phase I'm
going through so the actual seat height
You're Gonna Want For Your Vespa is
actually dependent wholly on your leg
length there's just videos like that
right yeah oh my God
yeah I mean um
uh aside from you know one you know
going through that phase I I've never
been sold on having a big ass truck or
driving a big ass vehicle what makes no
sense in anywhere else in the world yeah
yeah in my mind I'm always I'm always
thinking about parking no matter how no
matter how good the drive is parking is
always in the back of my mind and just
seeing that massive vehicle I know for a
fact that I'm like as much if I'm
enjoying this ride I'm going to like
Dread Park in this vehicle well you know
just get good just get good probably get
good yeah I say that but a lot of you
had to help me park one a few times when
we're in Japan yeah um but uh I mean in
America the parking spots are so [__]
big yeah so it's actually it's not in
the UK it'd be a miserable experience
because they're significantly smaller
like I I just don't think I would even
consider owning a truck or Jeep yeah in
any other country other than America
because it's just yeah it's like you're
actually just inconveniencing it'll
probably work in Australia could work in
Australia and probably some parts of the
UK actually could work yeah like the
countryside stuff yeah if you were if
you were not driving into the cities at
all it'd be fine but yeah if you're dude
like in America it's so easy to drive a
pickup truck because it's just that all
the lanes are big there's no roundabouts
everything's just lanes and every
parking spot is [__] massive yeah the
drive-throughs can fit trucks like it's
like this is this is ridiculous yeah I
used to drive through a drive through in
a seven-seater like Volkswagen people
carrier kind of family car in the UK and
that that was that was scary going
through the drive-through in there
because that was just about it would get
in right and the pickup truck no shot oh
yeah
um so yeah I don't know it's kind of fun
I just kind of liked it and the roof
could pop off it was fun man it just
felt like you were just above the road
like I I I I get there it's a tank right
yeah and I get the appeal because I
think like certain cars like if I
indicated I think they'd be like I'll
let him go
I think I think because if I was like
the big car they'd be like all right
fine okay come on through this man yeah
it kind of felt like it weirdly felt
like I don't know if it's because people
were just polite in Hawaii but from what
I when I'd been in the car a bunch when
driving with like either like American
friends or if I was an Uber like people
would not be that like generous no
they're like a Prius I don't know if it
was I don't know what it was maybe
what's gonna happen if you crash you're
not even gonna feel it you're gonna it's
gonna be like you know
it was fun it was it was great driving
it and it was uh yeah it was my first
time ever driving on the side of the
road same but it's weird how quickly you
kind of how easy it is to adapt yeah I
thought I thought I was gonna struggle
because it's going again against every
driving Instinct that I have like it's
already weird sitting on the other side
of the car soja Japan UK Australia all
drive on the uh left side yeah and
America obviously they're open the right
and most of Europe actually drives yeah
as well but uh yeah it is weird how how
quickly your brain I noticed that when I
was driving when I was following cars it
was super easy but as I was coming to a
junction if it was just me I would have
that brief moment of like oh yeah
turn wise yeah yeah yeah it's wide when
turning left I I have that a few times
when I was first on the vest Well we'd
come to like a teen succession if
there's no other cars yeah I'd have to
be like
way yeah and I'd want to turn left and I
almost [__] one time I almost went
into oncomes
terrifying luckily there's always cars
parked places yes sure help you figure
it out like yeah you you'd be surprised
it's pretty easy I think in Europe with
roundabouts it'd definitely be a lot
more uh tricky yeah yeah a lot more
intimidating yeah um especially if
you're doing like manual as well I don't
know
I think if you feel confident driving
generally I think it's fine yeah but if
you're not a confident driver in general
I think it's a little harder it's a
little scarier yeah I don't know if this
is a hot take but
I think that now now that I've you know
gone back to Thailand for a month and
just remind and just reconfigured my
mind
I think it's easier to drive in
Southeast Asia than it is to drive on
like like Western roads like America and
England
uh I I honestly I okay I think it's like
it's like the equivalent of saying like
it's easier to drink a cup noodle by
just Downing it you know what I mean
like it's like what because like because
when all rules go out the window hell
yeah it's easy to [__] drive because
you just [__] show up yeah like you
don't need to worry about the lights and
where people are just just do it I mean
that's the thing right because I I kind
of realized this because uh you know
I've lived I've lived in Thailand for
about like four years uh before you know
before moving to Japan so I have a lot
of driving experience in Thailand and
yes like the first like day or two that
you like drive there especially when I
came back this time I was like oh the
roads are [__] terrifying and then
when you get used to it you kind of like
you feel like every driver just enters a
kind of flow stage and that's that's cut
that's what it feels like it feels like
the traffic just has its own flow that
you you kind of like get a feel about
when you can go when someone's gonna
stop it's it's I mean I'm listening I'm
sure to Google something really I
because when we were in Thailand and I
was sitting on the back of those cabs I
I I felt nothing like that at all there
were so many like there were moments
where I was in the back of this cab yeah
and this so-called flow of traffic was
so [__] like start stop stop stop
that I was getting sick by the end of it
maybe it was the [__] driver as well but
like that's because the driver is an
ultra Instinct and you were still in
like your baseball you know you don't
think you know you you were the side
character you're like I can't tell
what's going on right now and the drive
was just like I understand everything
I'm like I can't see anything all I see
is an incoming crash right now what's
going on but oh yeah it's because like I
realized um because driving in Hawaii uh
yeah like trying to learn not trying to
learn but it's uh sometimes you're not
you're unfamiliar with the road yeah uh
I was probably the closest to getting
into a crash in Hawaii uh out of out of
this because you aren't following the
rules
following the rules I thought I knew the
rules that was a green light there was a
green light I thought I could just turn
I I just Googled because I was I was
near certain that like obviously the
reason why we have all these goddammers
for safety yeah it is yeah and generally
yeah I think in Thailand there's a
higher death rate oh yeah of course yeah
yeah I mean like it's why we have all
these boring rules and you can't go when
you want because yeah yeah traffic
accident yeah it but like I feel like it
definitely feels less uh
obviously it feels easier but once you
get past you know the intimidation of
everyone's doing their own thing it's
it's kind of like comforting to drive
there maybe I'm just like going back to
my bloodline like I said I think you've
just been in that situation too many
times now where it's just numbed you
because it's like it was definitely not
the case with me yeah yeah I would be
[__] [__] myself if I was if I
had to drive especially if I was on a
moped in Thailand oh my God yeah we'll
we'll do a trip around Vietnam or
Thailand or something get you a few days
on the road if I can survive that trip I
can drive anywhere yeah you know you
know like I feel like okay so you know
like The Stereotype you know uh we had
before that Asians are bad drivers you
know you know I I feel like there was
some truth to that and I feel like some
of that truth was there weren't bad
drivers they just went by the rules of
their home country which in Western
countries counts very much as a bad
driver
it's gentrified Asia
they were just bringing like the a the
Asian culture to America and America's
all like what what's going on here
they're bringing MMA rules to a box
British people have bad food they just
brought it from others exactly
yeah I mean like I still I like this
like the level Beyond me is I still
don't know how you know some people in
Vietnam or southeast Asia how they get
away with some of the [__] they tow or
like get on their scooters carrying
their entire family exactly that's just
dangerous like yeah like four people on
a scooter yeah I saw someone towing a
[__] Tree in Vietnam yes
they had this like tiny little trailer
that was obviously way too small for
this [__] tree and I'm like there is
no way that that is stable right now
we're about to get the [__] we're about
to get a tree on the [__] engine yeah
oh my God it does feel like a lot of
common sense goes out the window
sometimes just to like you're like yeah
I can yeah and they never stop to think
should I it's like I only have this
moped but damn I need this tree though
[Music]
[Applause]
just attached to a moped and a tree and
it's sliding on the ground I mean it
wasn't that much better honestly the
trailer the trailer looked like it was
like doing nothing every time they just
sweep out here
no way how the [__] did they hook up a
trailer to a moped
what the [__]
she's using every CC it's got just
Vietnam things man Jesus Christ but yeah
like uh yeah uh that's why I thought
driving I've I've
been in more close crashes in England
I think I think I'm I think it is gone a
bad Asian driver no coincidence
all I'm saying is I'm gonna help all I'm
saying is somehow I've never come close
to a crash in all my years of driving in
Thailand yeah
he put all of his skill points into
lockdown yeah
you're re-rounded by a white couple in
the UK right yeah what I mean I mean
that was I mean that wasn't my fault
it's of course
look that's that's what the insurance
company made like I said okay and
literally the guy the guy who rear-ended
me just said I just took my eyes off the
road for like five seconds and uh that's
how it always happens
when the eyes are on the road yeah
officer officer I just wasn't looking at
the road I'm sorry all right boys
if he crashed he didn't see it did he
really crash
oh my God have you guys ever been in any
uh crashes or Road accidents or anything
someone bumped our car once when we were
parking Amber that was really weird I
was just kind of like [__] was that
when was this we were sitting in the
back of the car we were like 10 right
and uh yeah we'd parked and some car
just bumped into us and it was it wasn't
like a big bump but if you've ever had a
car been knocked even like a little
knock really [__] like shakes the car
in a way they're like whoa what the [__]
that was weird that was about it I I
haven't been in one but I have seen one
like happen right in front of me and it
was [__] it was the place I lived in
London do you remember this the there's
like a junction there's always car
crashes happening there oh okay there's
a really high-speed car crashes it
happened quite a lot yeah and there's a
few times where they crashed
um and went into like people's Gardens
and stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah I had one
too where like my the road where I grew
up in as well it's like a like a
cul-de-sac but then it comes out onto
like a T intersection of the main road
and before they have a roundabout there
now to because there were so many
accidents in there but I remember when I
was in like Middle School I was like
walking to the main road to like go to
the bus stop and there was just this
like cyclist just coming up this hill
really really slowly and then just in
front of me I was looking at the cyclist
and then there was just a head-on oh and
this this cyclist probably went flying
about like 20 meters okay I was like oh
my God he he's dead like he's straight
up dead of course tough Australian that
he was just got up and he was like I'm
good he's picked up his bike and just
started cycling again
this bike was still good the [__] and
the driver was like are you sure you're
okay like I would I would have called a
soul Goodman bro I would have been yeah
ten times but in my head I was like the
only person who has the balls to get
into a head-on collision fly 30 meters
get up like nothing happened and then
continue cycling is someone that's
happened to him multiple times like this
because I think like in Australia at
least in Sydney like cyclists get into
so many accidents because it's like they
have to drive on the road yeah but they
don't have like a bicycle lane like they
do in like Japan like you know other
Southeast Asian countries so they're
just like in the middle of the [__]
road yeah and some drivers are like what
the [__] I'm gonna try and get around
them and then they either get it go into
uh you know uh the opposite traffic or
they just [__] bump the cyclist off
the road there should be enough room for
both to a little bit you'd think so but
Jesus cyclists think they own the
[__] road
am I right
one quick story and then I'll get on the
site okay so this is like this weird
experience had as a kid so
um it's not about cockroaches but it's
about cars
my mom in a supermarket I was like 10
years old
my mom's at the checkout and I I was
like ah can I just go and wait in the
car I don't know why I was like I was
like I want to go and play game boy or
something yeah and so I asked my mom can
I have the car keys and so I take the
car keys and I go to the parking lot and
I find uh the car and so I go to the car
and I put the keys in turn it it opens
and I go in I'm sitting in there and I'm
playing game boy like 10 minutes later I
look around the car and I'm like
I don't think these seats look the same
as the one in my car
oh what the [__] I look at the front and
I'm like that's that's not the front of
my mum's car either and I'm looking at
the seat again I'm like no this isn't
the car pattern at all I get out and I'm
like oh [__] this is the same car
but it's it's not our car and the key
worked on it
and apparently when I I looked it up and
it's it's like the chance of this
happening is super low right yeah
because the keys should only work on
like eight other cars in existence of
that model like it shouldn't work I just
thought it was really weird that it
happened I was freaked out as a kid and
I told my mom my mum didn't believe me
and I was like I'm telling you I went
over this other car and I sat in there
for 10 minutes I played my Game Boy it
would have been real awkward like the
owner of the car came yeah yeah yeah
well I was thinking maybe I should make
up someone came and beat me
but no it was uh yeah it was really
weird I remember that experience I did
something almost similar in Hawaii uh so
you remember when we went to Best Buy
yeah and uh I was like and someone
giving me the keys to the truck yeah
um so you know I was I was kind of like
yeah you know a bit of Space Cadets like
let me let me just go in uh go in and
Chuck get my wallet so I can buy what I
need to buy at Best Buy so I go to the
truck
and I try like opening the doors it's
not opening it's not opening it just
doesn't open at all I'm like what's
what's going on is is the batteries dead
or something and I try like several
times and then I was like okay let me
try let me let me try actually just
putting the keys in I'm I'm at this
truck for about two minutes trying to
[__] squeeze this key in this Jeep
that we've rented out for a day
literally like two minutes ago we parked
in as well yeah yeah
after about two minutes of fiddling
fiddling around uh guy walks up to me
and goes what are you doing that's my
truck oh that's that's my Jeep and I
look up and I'm like
I found myself at the wrong Jeep I was
trying to get I I felt so bad because I
was trying to get in this Jeep for like
a full-on three four minutes uh and the
the owner was just like right on the
other side apparently just [__]
watching me trying to break into his
truck oh my God you're lucky didn't like
[__] call the police yeah holy [__]
yeah you know what makes this story even
funnier our jeep was parked I [__] you
not two feet from the entrance yeah yeah
you're literally the first car you would
see as you come out and somehow God did
not remember he was he was in Best Buy
for a total of two minutes and they're
only like three other cars
in the parking lot how the [__] did you
[__] that up I don't know I don't know
there was one there was I I locked up I
saw one big ass car uh in front of me
and I looked down and I was like I just
assumed my head oh that must be mine how
many big ass cars are could there
possibly be was it the exact same model
um it wasn't the exact same model but it
was the same it was the same color it
was the same color and it was also a
we were literally in this Best Buy for
five minutes
oh my God yeah so that's what I was
doing by the way wow yeah we wondered
where did you go yeah and even like ah
no Noah oh okay okay all right sure you
shouldn't have the energy to explain it
all right I was [__] not good but
yeah yeah cycling cycling I had a
cyclathon oh yeah how was that yeah it
was fun uh so he cyclists do on the road
Joey uh people people get so annoyed
about that
um a lot of the times because some
people would um so yeah so if you didn't
know which I'm sure most you already
know uh cycle for nine days did a whole
lap of Kyushu
um let's raise money for charity and
streamed it and Chris is making a video
as well which probably won't be out this
one definitely won't be out by the time
this ass but look look out for that
there'll be a video on my channel as
well about it if you did miss it but
yeah we we streamed all day every day
raising money for the IDF
congratulations
200 and something thousand more dollars
than we raised last time yeah that's
insane um yeah I mean it was crazy
seeing how uh everyone was just really
into it this time okay it was like last
time we kind of dropped it like a week
before yeah and people were like what
like what are you cycling across why why
this is a weird stream uh but yeah
people were super ready for it this time
yeah we added a bit more Tech to it we
had I had a I had a Fitbit the whole
time that showed you my heart rate and
my calories burned so I thought it was
just trying to gamify it was showing
stuff on screen yeah yeah um yeah it
looked like a [__] breath of the wild
Hunt it wasn't literally like uh you're
watching a man cycling video game yeah
it was like biking simulator yeah I
wanted to bring the gaming aspect of it
the twitch is known for of course of
course and yet it went super well
um it was hard
[Music]
uh yeah I thought we had tough Hills and
Hokkaido and I was wrong we had way
tougher Hills oh yeah because Q's is mad
hilly yeah yeah I've learned that the
hard day most days were I think in
Hokkaido we had one day that was 600
meter incline turtle and that was the
hottest day right and then on average I
think we had around and that was just
one day and most days I think it ended
up being around 200 300 meters of uh
incline uh that that means like over the
course of the day you would have gone up
a total of 300 meters vertically yeah
and then probably down 300 meters
vertically
um uh in Kyushu it was on average about
500 to 600. damn and that's like that's
a big difference that doesn't sound
crazy because we were cycling on average
anywhere between 90 to 100 kilometers a
day and that doesn't sound like a lot of
incline compared to the distance we're
doing you're basically climbing a small
Mountain every day yeah well yeah so to
for perspective the Eiffel Tower is 300
meters yeah so we would sometimes be
doing double you're basically all almost
climbing like Tokyo Skytree every day
yeah because the Burj Khalifa is 800
meters yeah yeah so that's like you know
it's like a sky through 643 meters we
one day was 900 meters oh damn so one
day we did the Burj Khalifa and a little
bit of the Eiffel Tower on top so just
to like for the perspective of like how
high we would have to go up and then go
down with the distance right and so like
the thing is is that if the incline is
kind of like you know we have like a an
incline that's like that it's like okay
well if that's an incline over 10
kilometers it's like you can do it like
it's a little bit tough but but you can
do it but the problem is is that when
you get to inclines they're like this oh
yeah and you you can't cycle up that
like maybe if I was in the Tour de
France and like people would dude I've
got so many annoying messages like I
said I snapped and got so angry at they
were like just use lower gear and I'm
like no [__] just losing the lower gear
I you think I'd cycled nine days I
hadn't figured out how to [__] use my
gears they say well they sit and they
came here
[__] you tell me to use the lower gear
I'm in the lower ski on my bike has I
can't get up this [__]
um
and that's what it would like because we
we had a pretty like the objective was
every day is that for like generally for
safety we need to be done by Sundown
just so that we're not on the road I
don't know when it's night because like
yeah we have lights and stuff but it's
just like you can't see potholes well
you can't see stuff well I think I said
the last time we talked about it so
every day we had to be done so it was
like
some days well we would we would have
the hill right at the start and we would
have done like one-fifth of the distance
over half the day right because we would
have to stop and walk for an hour just
to get over one Hill which is like a
kilometer and a half right because there
was one Hill that was I think it was a
500 meter Hill continuously and we had
to walk up all of it over two kilometers
because it was just too steep yeah uh
and then the downhill was amazing but
it's like it wastes so much time so on
top of that you're also knackered all
day you're just tired and then you gotta
you gotta do this [__] and then the
weather was so bad we had such bad
weather this time
I thought Kyushu in March was pretty
decent weather it was like kind of it's
April May and June is where it starts to
rain a lot yeah mainly May and June May
June yeah it's where it gets crazy and I
thought okay if we go March we can miss
it because it won't be too cold it won't
be too hot and hopefully shouldn't be
too much rain uh day one I think we had
rain and then I think day two we didn't
have any rain uh and then I think day
three we didn't have rain but day four
we had like oh it was awful torrential
it was so bad it was like Noah's Arc
level rain
and it didn't stop the entire day oh my
God and
like obviously I'm not gonna like I was
complaining a lot on stream obviously I
was like [__] this [__] [__] this this
[__] sucks this is lame this [__]
because you're like you're you're
cycling and then the moment we left
um like I mean I let me actually show
you a little clever just give you some
context
the first cyclist to ever drown today
it's fine kind of getting wet because
it's like whatever but yeah you realize
how how [__] hot it is in your body
when you're wet for nine hours yeah like
you're actually just drenched for nine
hours and even
vessies I did not use vessels these
cycling issues the shoes get water
clogged water logged right away yeah so
like the the whole day even when you get
off the bike and let's say we have lunch
like we're walking around and we can't
change because like we're just you know
we're just doing it I don't even if we
did change it doesn't matter you're
gonna get wet again anyway and it wasn't
a warm day it was like 16 degrees so
you're just freezing the whole day and
the only time you feel kind of good is
when you're cycling
um because you kind of get a little bit
warm but it's like the mental fatigue
that takes on you is like insane and
then on top of that on the fourth day I
fell over like pretty badly uh we were
going pretty fast because I just wanted
to get going and then I went on to the
the pavement or the sidewalk yeah I saw
the clip yeah and they had like these
they have this stuff for blind people
um they're like these yellow lines and
they get really slippery yeah um in
there which feels like such a [__]
rain they get really slippery especially
with tires I went over it bite just
[__] went under me it's not
foreign
again God damn it again
I stopped at a light and my bike got
stuck in like where the pavement kind of
joins the road right it was kind of like
a little bit ditch and normally your
bike would be fine taking it but when
the rain it just doesn't have any grip
and it would just it just fell over and
I just went Face Forward over the bike
and then I really hurt my wrist but I I
don't again I don't want to complain
about it on streams I don't be able to
worry that I was like doing it unsafely
or anything
I mean I was fine I was doing it but it
was just tough
um but that day we raised a lot of money
yeah because people were like sorry for
me I saw like a graph of like the money
yeah there's a money raising them yeah
there was like an anomaly yeah just
because it was the most depressing [__]
it was so depressing and I was like I
was just on the verge of tears because
it was just such a mentally draining day
to just have to do that and then like
how did Chris take it uh I think Chris
was powered through he was listening to
Stalin audiobooks
I think Chris was like I think I was
obviously Miserable as well for Chris
but I think Chris was just like the one
thing about that I think is kind of nice
for Chris is that if he wants to not be
on the stream and he wants to just cycle
and just listen to the audiobook or
listen to the music yeah you can just do
that which is what I think is nice
whereas I always have to think about
like all right the strain The Strain The
Strain
um as well as obviously you know cycling
um and that was a and another tough
thing that comes with the rain which is
like the pretty the it's like they're
both equally as frustrating as it the
the like the tech that we're using does
not want to get wet at all and so like
we have to use like weird ass water
coverings and that's a problem because
that overheats everything yeah yeah so
halfway through the day like I couldn't
check my phone or anything so I was
streaming without seeing the chat or any
of the donations so I I for like the
last two hours I couldn't see anything I
don't know if we had signal I don't know
if the stream was working my bag was
getting soaked which is worrying because
then even though I had a water cover for
it the electronics the electronics it
was like it wasn't doing anything
because the rain was so bad and we were
in it for so long that yeah it was like
it didn't matter the water was getting
through somehow and so you're like oh my
God I can't see chat this equipment
might be broken I don't even know if
it's working it might not even survive
to the next day and then I can't see the
phone I can't see anything and I'm just
kind of talking to the camera and half
the time I wasn't even talking so I was
just so like miserable and sad that I
couldn't see anything and I had to go up
a [__] Hill in the rain it was so
[__] I hated it all and that was like a
day where I just like the next day I was
like I can't believe I have to get back
on the bike yeah that was like horrible
um and like my leg was also like my leg
was swollen because I'd fallen on it
pretty badly yeah and it was all it was
still kind of bleeding and stuff but I
mean it was like kind of stinging but it
was like find a cyclone and luckily the
next day thank God it was sunny and it
was like felt like a oh my god there was
a God
God smiled down I'm gonna be religious
because I just feel like if there was
another rainy day after that I think I
would have lost it yeah yeah and for the
rest of the the the kind of cycle we
didn't really have any terrible weather
it's kind of like we'd get a little bit
of rain for an hour it would stop yeah
it'd be a little bit of rain maybe the
clouds would come in we never really had
sunny days we'd like one day where it
was sunny which kind of sucked because
Hokkaido was pretty much all clear skies
until yeah in a few days it sucked but I
mean obviously you shouldn't cycle in
that weather normally yeah obviously if
we were smart we would have planned it
so we could just be like nope not
cycling today but we'll take a break day
but also I feel like the kind of the the
morale of it is like and the whole like
reason that I think the view is I I
bought my mind it's like this my weird
stream of mine like it's like you you do
it through the good and the bad times
right yeah yeah that's what makes it
like well that's the adventure right
yeah well that's that's why on that day
people donated like I think so right
like last day you know and yeah congrats
man yeah and that was a miserable day as
well because Chris insisted we go to
McDonald's and I was still wet and cold
and I was like can we take it to go
because she's like no no let's eat
inside and I was like
fine so I'm in this McDonald's I'm
soaking wet and I'm just eating
cheeseburgers and my leg is bleeding and
I'm like what the [__] I just want to go
back to the [__] let's just get out
of here I don't want to be in this with
a 40 minute drive to the Airbnb it was
the one that was the of course the day
where I wanted to get back quickest yeah
one day where the drive was super far
away yeah because we were in the middle
of nowhere in uh kyushi it was like yeah
we're like in a place called Izumi which
is like a town that has like one hotel
and it was fully booked so we had to
drive 30 minutes into some like Villa
and it was very nice but it was like
just like you were like come on by the
time I finally managed to get a bath it
was like 9 00 p.m and I was soaked the
whole day and I was I was like shaking
and freezing it was miserable
um but yeah I was really glad I did it
holy [__] was it hard that was hard it
was hard you gonna do another one I
don't know we'll see
like I think I think I would like to do
another one but I want to think about
how I can maybe mix it up a little bit
more yeah yeah yeah I think there's a
unicycle
tricycle oh my God
you're having a scooter call me not yeah
I have a pretty solid idea if I was to
do it again how I want to improve it and
I want to mix it up
um yeah I think I think uh if I did do
another one yeah I I have an idea but it
was good and I think people really
enjoyed it the the viewers ship was
generally higher for this one I mean I
think it kind of lined up really well
because uh you were able to like promote
it on the streamer yeah I was the best
to say yeah congratulations on winning
the best uh philanthropic philanthropic
event yeah philanthropic I learned that
word for the event as well yeah I mean I
yeah I think a lot of people are
surprised me too I think everyone
expected Jack to win I think I think
Jack was being what I said Jack Sean
yeah so it's so annoying that he has two
names yeah Sean God damn it man why is
Jack such an easy name to say as well
Jake no uh Sean's great Sean's awesome
and I think if Sean promoted it more he
easily would have won I think Sean Sean
was like ah you know I think Connor's a
nice guy
I don't know if this one I don't know I
you know but I also wouldn't have been
mad if I would have been upset I was in
thanks mess as well yeah which was the
other other event I was up against I
think because a lot of people were
expecting you know there were other
people nominated as well but I think
everyone was expecting thanks Mr Wynn
because it was just such I mean just the
pure fact that you're even nominated is
like yeah yeah I was I was you nominated
for two categories that I was nominated
in variety streamer which I didn't
expect to win either because it was xqc
was in the same category yeah yeah yeah
I mean that's just a different ballpark
viewership and you know his his audience
watches the streamer Awards and knows it
yeah so I yeah I think uh I I was I mean
I was honored to win anything I thought
it was hype that was the event itself it
was fun the stream rewards was really
fun uh there was so much drama that
happened afterwards as well I heard
about that yeah yeah
I saw the the [__] uh the [__] kid
that's everywhere came up to me you know
the kid who's in the Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton
there yeah he crashed it of course he
did no but he didn't get in he was
outside yeah so after the event ended
um we went outside and I was waiting for
my Uber to go to the the after party
because it's always an after party for
everything we were waiting there and the
Bill Clinton kid comes up to me
um but he's dressed as Boba Fett right
if you don't know who the Bill Clinton
kid is he's this guy who just who just
like video bombs stars and events he's a
very weird kid yeah the first time I'd
heard about him was at the game awards
the [__] Elden ring Japanese team
yeah and he starts going on about Bill
Clinton Orthodox reformed Rabbi or
something it was such a random it was
very bizarre
I don't know why he's turning up to all
these Awards ceremonies he's kind of
he's a meme because he's everywhere yeah
it's like spawning the yeti yeah yeah
and so he he came up and he he was in
this Boba Fett costume in his face he
was all covered up and he started
talking and I immediately could suss out
who it was from The Voice right and I
was like oh you're the Bill Clinton kid
he shoved his camera in my face and was
like where's Hassan where's Hassan I was
like what it's like literally here with
the flash on and I was like Paparazzi
yeah and I just was like get closer and
I put my face in his phone because I was
just like I was like what the [__] is
kid one and I was like yeah he'll come
out he'll come out and then he'd finally
I think he got bored because I wasn't
like pissed off yeah I was like oh cool
cool yeah put the phone in my face
that's fine
um and then yeah he then he left and
then kept harassing everyone else
bro
streamers have got Paparazzi now no no
not Paparazzi he's just him just him
just him there's no Paparazzi yeah he is
the paparazzi of Twitter I mean it was a
good like uh I I got to meet a lot of
other streamers I didn't know I was
surprised a lot of them knew of me I was
like oh thanks man well I mean like this
yeah the streamer Community is pretty
small yeah but I don't I don't really
once you're in you're in I feel like I
don't really collab with a lot of the LA
it's crowd I'm just gonna do my thing
yeah but a lot of them like know of you
it definitely helps you'll like homies
with Ludwig and yeah I mean it's it's
like you know the YouTube scene back in
2012 or something yeah I'm sure all of
the top YouTubers knew of all of the
other top YouTubers now and now like
there could be a guy with 10 million
subscribers that I literally have never
heard of in my life you know have you
ever like gone to a like a fresh YouTube
account and just like seen the
recommendations it's so weird to see so
many videos with like 100 million views
200 million views and some some
different Youtubers with like
it's like a global platform yeah and you
just like never heard of them ever you
know sure I think it's just yeah it's
just because it's different hours and
amount of content that is consumed and
by how much right yeah yeah so I think
that's why but no it was a good event
overall and I I enjoyed it there was um
they brought out like macaroni and
cheese and chicken nuggets for the
dinner
um that's a stream of diet right of
course that is yeah that's like gamer
died if I've ever heard one in my life
yeah
yeah it was um it was kind of over
pretty quickly but it was very fun and
uh I was I went pretty much just for
that and then I yeah
yeah the after party was fun and then it
got ended really early because another
content creator got too drunk and yeah
ambulances and stuff I don't know what
happened all I know is that I was
chilling and I try to stop the person uh
from going in the pool yeah and then I
was like all right go off I think I left
actually and then um next thing I knew
the security was like get out no one's
allowed in and I was like what damn I
was eating the burgers there's free
burgers how long did the party go on for
three hours okay it was like from I want
to say like nine ten no not even that it
was like two hours to like before
midnight and then right yeah and then it
kind of all just fizzled out
um yeah it was weird it was all night it
was it was weird hearing things through
the grapevine you know yeah because yeah
we ended up in like this weird like
everyone was like okay everyone's like
go here now because like when the when
the main party like if you ever had this
experience we've gone to a party yeah um
this is like a very
um like when there's too many people and
there's a venue yeah like and then the
venue say like they shot a tan or they
should at 11 I was like where do we go
next and then everyone everyone kind of
scatters and tries to like hear where
you going where are you going so we went
ended up going to this like club and we
just couldn't get in because it was full
and we were just standing outside for
like 10 minutes like what the [__] are
we doing I was like this sucks let's
just go let's just leave and then so I
was like no no wait there's this other
place and apparently there's
I've never heard of this there was this
house there was a credit card and the
allow the amount of credit you're
allowed to have was based on how much
social media following you had
what that is the most La thing I've
heard in my life yeah it was called uh I
think it's called carrot with a K as
carrot credit
as if people aren't clout Chasers enough
man now there's like a monetary value
that you can get with a credit card it's
like okay don't worry boys I'm paying
with Cloud yeah right now this is uh
yeah you're literally playing with Cloud
credit yeah
a new credit card for tick tockers
YouTubers instagramers who can't get one
from the bank so
what I think it is is they they just
give probably like outrageous uh what's
the uh what's the word apis is that what
it is uh aprs aprs yes credit apis they
probably just give I think they just
give outrageous credit uh like like if
you miss it you get absolutely [__] by
that yeah yeah and they hand them out
and it was like a house it was like
their house and I don't know like how
this all came about because like it was
just a house like a mansion and it was
it had branding of this thing everywhere
and we all just showed up and there was
white Claws and I I don't think they
knew I don't think that was the plan and
really weird I showed up and it was just
bizarre wait so hold on I'm confused as
to how this like credit system works so
it's like we go back to the credit thing
we're interested in that so it's like
you say so it's based on how many social
media followers you have yeah yeah and
so it's like is there like a conversion
rate of like yeah one dollar is one cent
or like but like but like is there like
a tick tock currency versus a YouTube
currency versus because like tick tock
tick tock followers it's not the same as
YouTube subscribers you know like an
exchange rate yeah
yeah it's from someone called whey this
is like their experience with it while
way wasn't able to share the specific
criteria for approval he says that there
are General follower accounts that
carrot looks at for applicants YouTubers
who generally have at least a hundred
thousand followers instagrammers should
have at least 125 followers and two
talkers should have have a whopping 2.5
million followers okay wait estimates
that the average card holder has an
annual income of more than five hundred
thousand dollars so Tick Tock is
[Music]
foreign
um and I I think yeah so I think they
just analyzed how much money like I
think YouTube they should look at your
ad rev and they're just like okay you
can have this much yeah wow so I think
it's uh really stupid idea um yeah yeah
so and probably something Silicon Valley
dreamed up and is absolutely [__]
stupid idea but they had a house and I
think everyone went that afterwards and
it was much smaller and so a bunch of
people were there and like I I drank a
white claw and I was like dude
I was like I'm done I was like I want to
actually want to go sleep well you
didn't sign up for the card no no one
had to oh it was literally just you turn
up and it was just that Brand's house oh
why they had a house I don't oh it's not
like a physical card no It is a physical
card all right but like this house this
house this house is like the the house
for influences or parties or something
yeah so we turned up and it was this
thing and it was the most shittest thing
ever it was just a mention for this
thing it just felt like a what a waste
of money for this company yeah well I
guess I know about it and we're talking
about it so maybe they got their money's
worth from that one party
um but what a [__] stupid idea for a
business
um can we get like a mortgage out with
that like how can I apply for like a
mortgage can I have a cloud mortgage
but the interest rate's pretty insane
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I need your analytics right now can you
send over your analytics is not great
and you could fall off at any moment
I need you to increase your CPM by at
least a Dollar by the next mom have you
ever been canceled please
declaration form where you like declare
like are you bringing in
for codex let's just
there's just gonna be have you ever been
Council I'm sorry we're gonna have to
deny your Visa
how many cancellation attempts has been
made in the past year please write down
our number
use the lower use the lower prick racket
to explain in more detail
it's like where are we going right now
oh my God holy [__] but yeah it was so
weird a lot of fun yeah it was it was so
weird because you know obviously only
you went and just obviously like the
drama happened and like seeing you
mentioned uh like because I can't
imagine what is what it is like to be at
the center of streamer drama because
it's kind of like I wasn't really
involved yeah I just happened to stop
the person from jumping in the pool one
time all right yeah and just like
hearing your name as part of this you
know gossip that was like being being
thrown around I'm like seeing your
friend's name in TMZ it's like what are
you doing that's kind of what it felt
like I was just like what's going on
and it was just like it was like someone
just came with like Chinese Whispers
where I was like some people are just
like oh come on people were people like
uh assuming it was a different Conor and
people were like saying different things
to what actually happened yeah I was
like hold on
yeah yeah they're like they were like
they're trying to throw Conor in the
pool I was like no no I was trying to
stop them from jumping in the pool right
yeah which is different to them trying
to throw me in the pool yeah I think so
at least
yeah so uh you've been to America yeah
it was literally like I went to America
I had one day back yeah and I went
cycling for nine days I had one day back
and then I went to Hawaii and now I've
got a few days back and then I'm taking
my parents around a little bit of Japan
so I don't know why I'm paying rent I'm
kind of just scamming myself yeah and
last year we spent a total of like how
long in Japan because we spent a lot of
it in America and traveling around like
half a year after half a year what you
know I I'm gonna try and at least have
like one or two months this year where I
just don't leave you man you say that
well I already yeah I mean or at least
make it so the visits out of Japan are
short yeah um except for pretty when we
go to America again for ax and stuff
like that we're going to Joey's not
going to join us this time though you're
going to Vietnam Loki actually really
[__] jealous actually really jealous
and be like damn that Joey God damn it
here I am in America again for the 50th
time and Joey back enjoying me back in
America
you know maybe maybe I'll ride around in
a Vespa in America who knows and just
get run off the roads are you scared to
go back in America after being grilled
at TSA oh yeah [__] hell like I got
[__] diddles I I I I I I had like my
guard down this time we went to Hawaii I
don't know why just because we've been
to America so many times that I've
forgotten how intense it could get yeah
you're in like hardest difficulty of
papers please like you were just like
you were struggling all the correct
paperwork and they still grilled him
yeah yeah I had all the correct
paperwork uh and I was like it's Hawaii
people are chill here it's an island
it's a tropical country I know how
things were people are very chill uh my
uh my border control officer was not
chill uh okay defeat the scene right I'm
at the front of our three-man line yes
and there's three desks yes there is two
men who look quite intimidating and they
don't they just don't look happy yeah
yes and there's this woman who seems
very pleasant and is talking very
friendly to all the people yeah yes and
I'm in my head I'm like man I sure as
hell I hope I get the very Pleasant View
yeah right yeah sure enough I go to the
the pleasant woman two seconds she's
like what are you here for business what
are you doing podcast cool bye have fun
in Hawaii I was like sick yeah so I go
downstairs because you're not allowed to
wait and I'm just sitting there like
like [__] it's been like 30 minutes
where the [__] are these boys yes
there's no way they're growing for 30
minutes because the line wouldn't
[__] move well I mean I always get
girl when I go to the States because I
think yeah so so I rock up I see kind of
having an easy time I'm like yeah it's
chill it's a way and I give my passport
he asks uh so what are you here for I
say business and he goes what are you
doing podcast exactly the same answer as
Connor said but he went further he was
like what kind of podcast what do you do
and I was just like oh uh I mean I have
a podcast where we kind of talk about
let's see this is where you [__] up
you've already sang Too Much one word
answers you gotta say one word answers
yeah just say anime anime you [__]
lie yeah I mean it kind of just like
okay
don't lie don't lie like this is
simplify don't talk to them yeah because
the guy asked me as well and I just said
Japan culture stuff yeah yeah that's it
three words the more you talk the more
they'll talk to you
yeah this is a trick with TSA chat right
I'm telling you this is well I I because
I figured this out if you just if you
start like uh um uh yeah I mean I guess
I talk about anime and stuff and he's
like well actually I want to trash take
you don't talk about anime at all
like I was in Like a Phoenix Wright
where he was just like that's a lie here
somewhere yeah there's a contradiction
oh that's just be calm yeah short simple
answers they'll they'll be like okay
cool yeah because again like we okay
just a preface we this is obviously
assuring you have all the documentation
yeah but they're still gonna Grill you
because it's part of that job which we
did but you can you can just make this
easier but just just kind of just being
simple being frank don't open up the
[__] essay yeah see because like I
was kind of you know I already knew
because every time I go to the US I
always have to get sent to the the
second yeah I knew I was just like you
know what I'm just waiting for him to be
like come to the back with me so I was
you know what does the bathroom look
like what's the nicest back room you've
been to yeah honestly probably
but it was so funny because like I got
sent to the back room in the Hawaii one
as I always do and they're like all
right just sit here he's already used to
this yeah this is like not my first
rodeo at all and I was just chilling
there you know just waiting for my name
to be cool just hanging out you know
watching these other people who clearly
look like they're [__] their pants
all right guys I'm a veteran don't worry
about it and uh and you know this tsa's
office is walking back and forth and one
of them stops and just like looks at me
dead in the eyes and I'm like you're
gonna call my name am I good to go and
he just goes is Aki with you today
I'm like
and he's like all right and he just
walks off and I'm like please put the
good word on in for me you know who I am
and sure enough like 30 seconds later
same guy walks out and he goes all right
you're good to go oh and I was like my
man he's like meanwhile as I'm in that
first part we're in the line with the
three of us you know I'm just waiting
for the guy to like just tell me the
inevitable and I'm hearing in on God's
conversation and he's like so uh
I'm like what conversation did it come
to we have to explain among a publishing
company to a TSA like what did he ask
you he basically so I know the exact
moment where I was just like I [__] up
basically because he was asking me all
the questions and you know that was fine
but he just kept going right
um because I feel like he was looking
for
something
some kind of horse something he could
grab onto so he asked me what do I do I
said anime uh anime and manga podcast
and he was like what are you here for I
was like uh anime convention and he was
like what's the anime convention and he
was like Hawaii con and then he goes so
uh where's cool icon taking place we'll
see what's the address actually while I
was going through my thing I heard him
you being grilled of like how will you
get there yeah how will you know where
you're going and I was and to be fair I
was actually like I wasn't panicking I
was actually like pretty calm I was just
like sorry sorry about this uh let me
let me go check it now uh and I uh I was
normally I changed my SIM card to like a
SIM card that works in America now with
American data after I land uh and so I
was like let me let me check it quickly
no I would just like connect to the
Wi-Fi he's like there's no Wi-Fi
you cannot check your phone there is no
Wi-Fi and I was just like um is it okay
if I change my SIM card he was like no
what is the address I need to know now
and I'm just like holy [__] I'm like
he's [__] playing doctor in my mind I
was like dude chill
you could just been like ah my someone
else in my party knows yeah yeah so
that's that's literally what I did and
uh he was like he looks behind and he
was like is he with you and this one
obviously wasn't a good look he's gonna
like [__] drag this wasn't obviously
wasn't a good look be me he's like he
sees me and he sees my mate Joey also
being grilled what's he gonna be taking
the guy who's gonna take it in the
background yeah
the guy taken to the back room he's like
that's your boy that's your boy right
there yeah
yeah
I'm like uh Joe what's the Adventure
Center called again uh and he's uh on
another convention center and it's uh
yeah the Honolulu convention center and
I was like oh it's a Honolulu convention
that and he he was just like how are you
going to get that how yeah I heard him
grilling you yeah yeah he he kept he
kept asking me how am I going to get
there and I'm like and I I didn't know
what he was asking for so I was like I
thought I thought he meant where are you
staying so I was like I don't know like
how like are you getting a taxi or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh he
was and so I was like oh I'm gonna get a
taxi to
um a taxi to The Modern Honolulu which
is where I'm staying beforehand and he's
like no how are you gonna get there and
I was just like what what I don't I
don't know anything I don't I don't
understand what you're looking stupid
dude like sometimes they like
occasionally they're not pretty normal
question is you know do you have any
cash on you yeah yeah so they can trick
you that's what the guy asked me yeah
yeah they ask you that because they want
to know if like I guess if you need to
do something yeah you can you know do
you know what got me through what
because actually if this wasn't my first
time in America I probably would have
been [__] myself but I know he's
just doing his job
the lawyer told me this as well like you
have all the documentation yeah you've
done everything incorrect like yeah
they're just trying to intimidate you
yeah they they if you have all the
documentation yeah you haven't said
anything that's in like out breaches
your like terms of that Visa or whatever
then they you know they shouldn't do
anything yeah I mean like like in my
mind I was just like this is not legal
advice by the way there's not legal
advice it's not legal advice yeah this
is my like I said it's my first time I
definitely would have been [__]
myself but I was just like oh this is
this is very much an inconvenience right
now and I know it was it was just
because I it could have easily been sold
if I had data on my phone and it just
was one of the airports that did not
have Wi-Fi at the border so you know I
was just in a little sticky situation
but I was pretty cool how I wanted you
know how I want them over why start
complaining about LAX oh
wait how did that even come up
um what's your least favorite airport
because he because he asked me um is
this your first time in America and I'm
like no fly to uh fly to L.A all the
time I just did a tour of America as
well this you know I've been through
I've been to the Border enough times
obviously he's like checking that as
well and he's like oh
how does how does this airport compare
to uh he asked you there he asked me
that he asked me that he answered that
and I'm just like I'm gonna lie to you
uh this is uh this is way better this is
this is such a good airport officer
okay and he looks around and he goes
really and and then I just I don't know
and then I just start going off an LAX
and I'm just like you don't you
you how good this is compared to LAX my
God oh my God he didn't ask me I'd have
been like bro this airport is a dog I'd
have been like he'd have been like
denied
yeah he's here what and as soon as I was
like going off my LAX he just looks at
it and goes all right you can go through
hope is not too hard I was just doing my
job I was like yeah
yeah totally understand man I totally
understand you're just doing a job
unless you said that oh yeah yeah yeah
at least he said that you know he was
pretty loud with you there I I I don't
know if it's doing his job we get a
little something out of that he was
pretty loud he was definitely being very
loud and in my opinion very excessive I
think my my monk training kind of like I
kind of like came through maybe maybe
like exuded onto him somehow because I
was he was grilling me and I was just
like
you know I'm sorry man I can't check it
right now I come here in peace line
through LAX dude I watched two episodes
of Maiden Abyss while I waited in the
immigration line
because I do it's so [__] it's so bad
how like understaffed LAX is yeah and
like I'm like this is so stupid that I
can watch an hour of anime in the
[__] line and you got to like the uh
officer you're just like I'm sorry
officer I just watched made in Abyss
it's a better episode I think I was on
like episode 10 of season two as well
and I was like [__] this is heating up
how far away
I guess we can do animation okay we can
do a little bit of anime
let's not talk about it the anime okay
um so what what was the first thing you
did after you got off to uh Hawaii since
uh me and Joey just went off and rested
and uh what did you do corner
what did I do you went to go see a
certain movie oh you went in Hawaii yeah
so I so John Wick 4 doesn't release in
Japan until September all right which is
like what the [__] why is it just how
long does it take to make subtitles yeah
like that's that's like six months
translate as a crying right yeah some of
the scenes are in Japanese like what
what I don't understand why it's taking
so long to get John Wick 4 out and so
like I'm a massive fan of the John Wick
series I've watched like every single
one in the cinema when it came out I
[__] loved it they're great and like
I I think they're like the best action
uh I guess what would it be called it's
not a sequel or Trilogy it's a
quadrilogy yeah series it's the best
action movie series I think we've had in
like
for such a long time like even some of
the greats of action movies like I think
this holds up if not is better than a
lot of my favorite action movies damn
yeah and so I was you know and John mc4
looked insane they had such an insane
cast of goats uh and so I was super
pumped for it and I realized okay well
it's the week after John Wick comes out
in America we're in Hawaii and there's
got to be a theater in Hawaii sure
enough there was one right next to the
hotel uh so the moment I found out that
we were like the time we were arriving
like 12 I booked the cinema for 2 2 p.m
I was like I'm going straight to John
Wick when I land so we got in I said I
booked three seats to John Wick right
you picked three six he booked three
seats because I was like if somebody
last minute wants to join they can join
if not I get the extra two next to me
because he was like packed yeah of
course because everyone wants to watch
John Wick yeah because it's John [__]
Wick you want to watch it so
I had like they were like recliner
chairs too dude theaters theaters in
America are so [__] they are the food
is the food is insane in the state I got
a chili dog and I was fearing for the
worst that it was going to be like the
spray chili it was like actual cheese oh
it's not chili and a great hot dog and
the popcorn was great it was massive I
was so happy and so know all your
favorite things nobody came with me
no I wanted to watch John week 4 can you
believe that well to be fair I haven't
seen a single job yeah I haven't seen
the third one yeah I will I will come on
come on and so I just immediately went
there and I was so happy and it was it
was rammed so I was kind of happy to
have the two seats next to me it'd be
free
um and then one guy tried to sit next to
her he's like I was just my seat I was
like it's certainly not your seat I'm
like boom boom boom it's my shoes buddy
I would say like you could sit next to
me I was just saying like no no it's
actually not your seat actually I booked
up all these seats for myself which is
great because I had like I felt like
[__] and also I'd ordered way too much
food yeah so I had to like I was like
putting my [__] on the other places and
like I could because they gave me this
giant ass tray for all this food and I
don't know how I would have managed to
eat anything if I had just the my lap
because I would have been like so I just
put things away and it's great I loved
it I guarantee everyone else in that
Cinema was like look at this fat [__]
yeah because we hadn't eaten so I went
to town like this is like a lunch
breakfast I always do that I was living
my best life it was three hours long too
holy [__] [__] it was so good it was so
good and like so was it the same length
as Avatar uh yeah no I was a little
longer I think actually okay three and a
half hours all right it was three
something either way John Wick was I
like normally when you come off a plane
you might be a little sleepy but there
was no sleep at all this movie was so
[__] good this is insane it was such
a good film best one out of the four
what's your what's your favorite one
yeah what's what's your John Wick's here
yeah it might be my favorite one I mean
it's got Donnie Yen
he's so [__] good in it yeah like
obviously we've talked about how much we
like martial arts films yeah is the goat
I never realized because I don't think
I'd ever watched a Donnie and film where
he speaks a ton of English his English
is cracked and I think because his I
think is in one of the videos I watched
his mom uh opened up her uh martial arts
thing in Boston it was crazy how well
all these new characters just fit right
in it really felt like the one that
um I guess because it just focused on
ending it didn't like some of the law
that they kind of built in some of the
other John Wick movies we kind of felt a
little bit convoluted yeah and this one
it was just action like I think he says
a total of like 300 or is it a 300 180
words like he says barely any words in
it right yeah and the action scenes are
so goddamn good so wait is this the last
film is it the last drama right uh at
least in terms of yeah
um before John was like yeah it is this
is like an end of Ava kind of deal
where's no no it's the last one
it's so [__] good and I was like it
made my week it made it made going away
worth it I would have gone a lot I think
I would have gone to Hawaii and if I'd
gone on that if I'd have flew do I
watched Sean wake got on the flight back
that evening I'd have been happy yeah
I'd have felt like it was worth it it
was genuinely amazing like it was such a
good film all right holy [__] watch John
Wick 4 if you haven't already yeah
honestly like you'd think going to
Hawaii for the first time he kind of
would not stop talking about like some
of the stuff he experienced in Hawaii
but in Hawaii he just kept talking about
his highlight Being John Wick dude it
was so good like actually the one of the
best films I've watched and so I'm so
[__] happy it turned out good so good
Donnie ends The Goat in it as well he's
so good yeah would you like do how do
you feel like John Wick Stacks up
against the classic like action movies
because I feel like you know you had
like the classic 80s action movies and
then that kind of like the rambos yeah
like the rambos and like the
Schwarzenegger kind of era and I feel
like action movies are kind of
[Music]
you know fast the whole Fast and Furious
franchise uh like the John Wick
franchise now as well to be a little bit
of a SIM for a moment like I mean Kano
obviously works very hard and has his
entire career on like martial arts yeah
so like even though he's a great actor
he's also a great stunt man and martial
arts person I guess the practicer and
like it's like the the accumulation of
all his career of practicing different
elements of uh stunts and martial arts
just coming together it's like I don't
think of an I can't think of another
like actor who is more like a
traditional actor who has invested so
much into this kind of space who could
pull this off like this because like you
watch I watch action movies after
watching John work and I'm like holy
[__] the amount of cuts and shaking at
the camera is insane it's like you watch
John Wick you're like oh that was a 30
second uninterrupted camera angle of him
just doing an amazing choreographed
fight and it's like holy it's like the
old school like Jackie Chan film yeah
it's so good it's so impressive and like
the the mixing of the the style like
martial arts with like guns is so cool
and it's just like I personally I think
this is probably like it's John Wick 4
kind of sealed it for me where this is
like probably my favorite action series
of all time right I think genuinely for
me uh maybe not like martial arts but
like for just yeah I think it's my
favorite of all time yeah I genuinely
think so it's so fun the whole world is
Fun the whole assassin world is very fun
and engaging and like God it's just so
good maybe it's recently biased but [__]
is it fun I don't I don't know why that
you know every time Keanu Reeves stars
in the film I don't know why I love the
fact that Keanu Reeves just plays Keanu
Reeves he's so dedicated to everything
and just the the craft of amazing one of
the most wholesome persons yeah right on
the face of this Earth yeah right I
think it's just because you could again
I think there's that feeling where like
you when you watch someone who just
loves what they do yeah and is dedicated
to the craft and and it's a nice person
on top yeah that's a great person like I
think it's just hard not to just like I
think even if you don't like action or
don't care for the John Wick series I
think you can't deny that watching him
perform on the screen is just like a
delight yeah you know and dude some of
the stunts that he does is like holy
he's 50. and there's some of these
stunts he's doing is insane I just I the
whole world of the series is just insane
it's please watch it if you haven't I
know it's not for everyone but it is
such a delight to watch the thing is
though after I see off you know after
I've seen John Wick one and two at least
it's just ruined any other role that
he's played because all I see is John
Wick now you know I I watched like the
new Matrix I'm like this is just John
Wick in The Matrix you know I played
cyberpunk 2077 I'm like is this John
Wick and cyberpunk Neo cosplay John
Wayne because he's just like he just
plays he can no in the best and worst
way it's just like I only see like Keanu
Reeves or the John Wick area you know
which which is great which I I [__]
love it's the beard man it's I think it
is the beard his look is Iconic yeah
it's it's iconic look
just do martial arts and a suit is just
a [__] nice to watch I don't know why
it's so good it's anything in the city
God the home you should please watch
John Mike he was like this old [__]
week yeah I was like I was like I told
like this just to nobody they were
eating dinner I was like guys John wait
for please watch it kind of would have
random conversations with people in like
the lift uh just talking about John Wick
four that's how dedicated
how's your day going my day's going
great I just saw John Wick I I'm like
the precursor to like what the Rick and
Morty fans became for John Wick like I'm
like have you seen Rick and Morty you
have to watch Rick and Morty oh my God
I'll get bored of it in a week but my
when it comes down to Japan again I'm
gonna go watch it I might have caught up
with the uh yeah because then I'll be
six months and I'll be like God I want
to watch it again I know I do such
Delight dude so [__] good yeah I mean
there's kind of like a lot a lot of
films coming out that interest me which
is rare you know we have like the Super
Mario Brothers film coming yeah I think
I think we've kind of now seeing kind of
like the the you know when roughly now
is I think when films kind of stop being
affected by the pandemic as much yeah so
I think we're kind of getting more films
well it's the past two years have been a
drought it's just it's just nice because
the past few years and it doesn't it
doesn't even feel like the past two
years it feels like the past like four
or five years has just been hey Marvel
movies which is great I enjoyed endgame
you know I enjoy I'm I'm still as much
of a Marvel fan even as you can be as
even though like phase four as brothers
no one likes this face as a soccer ass
um and I was hoping Ant-Man would be
better it wasn't it was did you watch it
I I was going to watch it and then I saw
reviews and I'm like okay this is a
plain movie easily swayed by reviews eh
hey I mean I I kind of am because
especially when it comes to like theater
going to the cinema I I want to make
sure I'm not wasting my time yeah I'm
that guy it's either Cinema or I watch
your home or if it's a Marvel movie
that's mid I'll probably watch it on a
plane you know which is what I've what I
have been doing with like the rest of
the movies this entire yeah
um so it just seems like there's not
been exciting now yeah there's not been
there for a long time there just wasn't
a lot of choice of films that I wanted
to see if it wasn't like a Marvel movie
but now there's like so many films are
like [__] is there new uh that film I
want to watch I think it's coming out
this series The Open Oppenheimer movie I
really want to watch it yeah oh my God
what's his name oh my God uh [__] I I
was literally about to say it
Christopher Nolan that's it it's
Christopher Nolan and oppenheim is
played by because oh my God what's the
guy's name Kyle look it up
starts with a K he's the guy in sunshine
oh the actor Killian Murphy Killian
Murphy yeah he plays like Oppenheimer
the guy who made the atomic yeah
[__] awesome yeah I'm really high
we're gonna have a good year of Cinema
hopefully yeah I'm really really hopeful
yeah I don't know Christopher I've
realized exciting movies he does he
makes I what I love about Christopher
Nolan is that even if his movies you
know sometimes are a bit experimental at
least they like break the mold I don't
feel like I've like when I watch the
Christmas when I watch the Christopher
Nolan movie I always come in with a new
experience right
um even if a lot of his movies have had
because some of his movies have had
issues with it I look back to all of his
movies and I'm looking back at tenant
now I'm like damn that was actually a
really good you [__] experience one
thing you can't say about his movies
that are boring yeah like they're always
interesting even if they're hard to
follow they're always [__] Delight to
watch yeah every every now and again I
go back to watch clips of Lieutenant
like on YouTube because I just want to
like relive just how [__] insane some
of the visuals in that world yeah and of
course tenant had problems with this
writing I mean the character was
literally called the protagonist but
like yes like which which is how like
it's you know a lot of the reviews of
that movie were pretty like mediocre no
it's not his best work but when you look
back on an experience five like two
three five years in the future you're
not gonna remember any of that stuff
you're gonna remember the [__] that
actually like did something new yeah you
know which stands out on like the
broader scope of like Cinemas that came
out yeah yeah for sure yeah like I look
back at Interstellar as well I've been
I've been I watched that again I
actually rewatched that as well because
wait why I don't know that's a [__]
good news something about it was just
stuck in my mind
it's it's a really really well here's
the thing again when it came out when I
first watched it I came out of it after
watching what's the Dream movie again
um Inception yeah Inception was what
like sold me on Christopher Nolan that
was that's what made me a Nolan Fanboy
watching that in cinemas in Japan
actually for the first time [__] blew
my mind and I'm like this is incredible
I went into Interstellar wanting
something similar to Inception I was
like this is totally different what is
this I don't understand and the reviews
at that time were again this is still
good not his best work but still good
but it's just something about his work
just sticks with you yeah like makes you
remember it and I think I appreciate
installing more now than I did when I
first watched I think I watched I think
I like I never because I think before
that time I wasn't really going to the
cinema much yeah um but I think for some
reason in my head I since I watched at
Astra I was like I don't want to watch
any more space movies I don't know why I
watched this at Astra thing and it was a
really weird Okay film I remember I went
to the cinema and it was literally just
me
there's like a midnight viewing of it
and it was IMAX it was giant theater and
it was just me all right and I was like
man this is creepy as [__] it was such a
really sad movie as well I mean you
remember it right yeah yeah so I think I
was done with space but I kind of want
to get back into space stuff have you
watched the Martian I haven't watched
that either again because I I was kind
of done such a bang of films
like a lot of films I'm like I want to
watch down the theater but I can't
anymore yeah like the Martian to me is
like a modern day Castaway that's that's
also a movie that's aged incredibly well
holy [__] Matt Damon [__] killed it
in that film man making those potatoes
yeah you're making those potatoes I'm
just like a game theory a film theory
about it yeah I was like I've seen the
Martian
he plants the potatoes yeah fine he uses
it I think now we've got all the cool
science YouTubers and everyone you know
bringing a good name to scientists but I
remember back in the day it was just
like he was like he was like the pioneer
of like bringing a cool image to like
someone who's just really nerdy and
someone super into science yeah I
remember watching The Martian I was like
damn maybe I should get into like a
science or something like that
I want to grow potatoes on Mars God damn
man yeah yeah what a banger film I think
the reason I go to the cinema less than
what I used to
um is I don't know where I saw this
quote or it was probably like a random
Youtube short or YouTube video or
something like that but uh get all my
life lessons yeah yeah yeah I I remember
what they were talking about but it was
someone in the movie industry talking
about how you know in the modern day
there's there's not really as many mid
budget movies anymore you know it's it's
it's always either the super high budget
Blockbusters which is normally like
anything Disney anything Marvel that has
its own charm but I'm not always in that
kind of mood or you know or it's like a
very like super Art House yes like super
like indie film or house kind of films
and it kind of made me realize yeah I
think some of my favorite films are the
aren't those big ass Blockbusters you
know the cinema kind of experience it's
kind of like it's kind of like I grew up
with watching a lot of mid budget kind
of uh mid-budget movies well there's a
lot more there's a lot more you know
like you could make comedy movies before
you can't make economy yeah what's
happened to comedy movies man not
profitable I watched like a 50 minute
like breakdown of like why comedy movies
are just dead now like DVD sales are a
big thing yeah yeah having DVD sales to
make up the poor performance against
Cinema and you can also shoot them a lot
cheaper but I you know I guess the
audience demand for it is not as high
enough comedy is dead yeah I think about
like mid-2000s how many of the most
iconic films from the mid-2000s are just
really just think of like how many
[__] animals
you know people love to clown on Adam
Sandler especially like some of the
later films he did but he did some
really good [__] films and I really
enjoyed that era of just oh it's an Adam
Sandler movie I I should probably watch
this like dude like honestly like it's
weird that it's those like weird kind of
as you were saying like mid to like
slightly high range comedy movies or
like movies or just movies like that in
general yeah that like that just stick
with me the whole time because like in
my head like when I think back to like
some of the most fun movie experiences I
had like I don't know if this is like a
hot day Night at the Museum was a
[__] movie do you remember that movie
yeah yeah that was a [__] awesome or
like Bruce Almighty like yeah exactly
those kinds of like it's such simple
films but there's something about it
that just like after all those years I
can still quote like a bunch of things
from those movies right when it's like
today it's like I've seen a lot of great
films recently but it's like yeah I
couldn't tell you as you know in detail
as much as like say like you know
[__] Water Boy by Adam Sandler you
know I mean it's just a different like
it's a different landscape now like
everything has to be a lot of money a
lot of the time I mean like [__]
superheroes are the isekai of Hollywood
you know it's you you just have like no
choice but superhero movies so so when
something like John Wick 4 does come out
or you know the Super Mario Brothers I'm
like finally something different yeah
well they thought or initially the John
Wick was gonna not perform the greatest
because there was like not really much
marketing behind it it was kind of
confusing initially because you're like
just a reaction movie with piano okay
I'm having a guess
I think people just were shocked at how
[__] good it turned out yeah like the
budget was Tiny for the first John Wick
and even the newest one was really like
kind of kind of small considering how
famous John Wick is I think it can you
Google the budget but I think it was
like 90 million oh really not a lot that
yeah which like these Marvel movies
sometimes like 400 500 million yeah like
yeah like it's a it's a very different
amount of money yeah yeah exactly yeah
100 million which is like is a lot of
money don't get me wrong but like when
we hear about what some other films cost
yeah like I think Avatar needed to get a
billion to like break even or something
it was like you know it's just like holy
[__] like it's so impressive what they
can do yeah I don't know it's I just
love it yeah I mean like like you like
you were saying there's a there were a
lot more films in that like 50 50
million kind of like this would be a lot
too 50 is a lot but yeah I mean
inflation is all sort of things yeah
yeah but like I mean like that kind of
like budget compared to the the every
superhero every Marvel movie which is
like hundreds of millions of dollars
it's all they're both a lot of money but
one is way more money than the other
kind of movie and I feel like in that
like mid-range you could still explore
interesting ideas without having to be
limited by you know being an indie film
you know because indie films are [__]
fantastic by the way but at the end of
this at the end you know at the end of
the day you are you you use the
resources you have and sometimes they
find clever ways to use like the lower
budget but it's it has its charm but
there's there's just a whole category of
like films that I feel have just been
wiped off the Earth in like the past
decade because a lot of the [__]
budget films we hear about lately are
like cocaine bear and the Winnie the
Pooh horror films yeah it's like there's
just [__] films it's just [__] stupid
they're just meme films right yeah yeah
they're just films that they're like
it's like uh you can make the film on
less than a million yeah and you'll
probably get more money just of people
being curious because it's such a stupid
concept yeah like I think the Winnie the
Pooh film was like not even like 100 how
much was the Winnie the Pooh horror film
I was really tempted to go walking I
think it was like literally like less
than a million like I think it was like
even less than that I think it was
something stupidly low I mean I wouldn't
be surprised yeah it just says
and everyone knew that that movie was
coming out right and so I don't think
the aim of that movie was to make a good
movie I think it was to make a movie
that would just exist and it could be
called a movie
yeah wait wait wait it's like 10 to 10
extra budget yeah easy got a million
yeah
a 10-day shoot fast that's just that's
just a YouTube video
yes let me yeah so so like I think a lot
of Studios now or like like budget so
you're saying like oh wait if we just do
something outrageous somebody saying
[__] stupid that people are going to
talk about online yeah even the movie
sucks it's not crazy that the Winnie the
Pooh movie took just as long to film as
our Japan road trip oh my God why are
you gonna say it like that oh my
what other Classic Movies should we
remake today it's Moana it's Moana guys
[__] idea I mean everyone ever
I mean everyone said this but like the
remix [__] suck well there's that
Little Mermaid remake coming out right
yeah
Moana does not need a live action and
the fact that they have Dwayne Johnson
doing it which makes sense obviously
yeah but what is the [__] point now
yeah when it's just like an RTX version
of Moana like what is the point of this
movie he just did a mocap version he
just [__] used the mocap footage of
him release that like what is this [__]
he's gonna be like I'm really excited to
revisit the role and do the exact same
thing I did five years ago yeah the
thing the thing about remakes is that I
feel like with remakes you should
there's there's like a great everyone
everyone thought about it everyone knows
this it was just an Unwritten rule that
you should leave it the [__] alone for a
while yeah like like you can't call it a
remake if it's like what [__] five
years ago if I could still watch it on
in-flight entertainment it's too goddamn
early okay too early but boys we all
know the biggest news in the movie world
is that Shrek 5 was just announced was
that actually yeah Shrek five was just
no [__] worth making a Shrek five I
watch Puss in Boots oh you did it's
insane really it's so [__] good I
actually I I've never seen a movie that
went so hard I really want to watch it
that's actually like that's no joke it's
in the cinemas right now yeah I heard
insane things about it yeah dude it's
like it's it's like it feels like the
one punch man of the Shrek Universe in
terms of like it just came out of
nowhere and was like what the [__] why
is the animation just insane yeah the
the it's I can't fathom how hard they
went on this film not only is like the
just the animation itself just an
absolute Delight the story is so [__]
good yeah yeah I I mean when I first saw
Puss in Boots to start like trending on
my timeline I'm like people are memeing
right this is this is a meme I don't
even watch Puss in Boots one you don't
need to because this thing was just so
[__] good yeah damn
um but yeah I'm excited for into the
spider-verse too as well
thank god hell yeah even though that is
a superhero film I don't care
right now bro that film was so good dude
I'm please if you if you're skeptical
you're like I don't want to Puss in
Boots I don't watch [__] boots it
doesn't [__] matter don't [__]
listen to anything you say you're dumb
don't watch Puss in Boots too I don't
care how you watch it watch it it right
now it's so [__] good yeah more of
the story is I am more excited about
cinema this year than I have been for a
very long time and I might actually and
I'm going to the cinema more often now
yeah dude please do let's go watch for
some beers I think it's still in cinema
but hey look at all these patrons though
I bet they're excited for Shrek five yes
why would they be okay never mind thank
you for watching patrons
all right hey if you enjoyed the show
and you would like to support it then
make sure to go to our patreon
patreon.com
Twitter send us to memes on the
subreddit and you can hear the faceless
to us on Spotify and uh we will see you
guys next week bye
[Music]
thank you